[Music]
today we're going to cancel everybody
involved
in making this happen on twitter
yesterday
kaepernick was trending and twitter
provided
this explanation or context they would
say for the trend
they said as tom brady makes his way to
another super bowl some football fans
are pointing out that the quarterback's
politics
i.e his friendship with donald trump
haven't derailed his career in the way
that colin kaepernick's peaceful protest
of police violence did
arguably leading to his exit from the
nfl
okay now just to give additional context
to twitter's context the people making
that claim
are not football fans a football fan
knows that comparing colin kaepernick to
tom brady is like
well it's like comparing colin
kaepernick to tom brady there's no
analogy i can draw that would be more
absurd than that
and as if to illustrate my point that
the people making this comparison
cannot really be football fans here's a
woman called samantha palino
and she says in her bio that she dances
on broadway
and she also gives her pronouns now i
don't want to stereotype but my
immediate assumption
would be that samantha the broadway
dancer with pronouns in her bio
probably isn't a football expert
i would guess and my suspicions are
potentially confirmed by this she says
quote as we approach another tom brady
super bowl
let's remember he's friends with trump
and has endorsed republicans in their
policies
while one of the greatest quarterbacks
of our generation colin kaepernick
had his career derailed for kneeling
during the anthem hashtag
hypocrisy samantha you're not doing
your gender any favors um with
statements like that
one of the greatest quarterbacks of our
generation colin kaepernick
this is true in the same sense that pete
davidson is one of our greatest
thespians and eric swalwell is our
greatest statesman
which is to say it's not true in any
sense at all
so i can't believe i have to do this but
let me let me let me just give you
some of the numbers here especially
maybe if you're not a football fan
and you hear a claim like this just i'll
give you a few numbers you can throw out
there
uh to to correct the record colin
kaepernick had a career completions
percentage of 59.8
which is not very good um with uh with
72 touchdowns against 30 in their
interception
in his final three seasons he went eight
and eight
then two and six then one in ten as a
starter and was eventually benched for
blaine gabbert
which is the football equivalent of
losing an arm wrestling match to your
niece
all that said you know he did have some
historic moments on the football field
like when he threw
two pick sixes in a row on the first two
drives of the game against the cardinals
in 2015.
um very few qbs have ever done that in
fact i think he might be the only one
to start a game his first two throws
were uh
were intercepted for touchdowns now
let's consider tom brady
tom brady has never had a losing season
in 21 years
he has six super bowl rings 10 super
bowl appearances
he owns the record for the most playoff
wins most playoff completions most
playoff
passing touchdowns like 50 other records
he left new england at the age of 43
went to a previously mediocre tampa bay
team
and immediately brought them to a super
bowl too i don't like saying it or
admitting it but he is the undisputed
greatest football player of all time
and there is no other credible candidate
for that position
period he has won as many nfc
championships as brees and rogers and
he's been in the conference for one year
and he was 43 again so this guy's the
michael jordan of football only better
because jordan played on a different
team in his 40s
and didn't have this kind of success at
all so
if you're wondering that is why tom
brady has a career and colin kaepernick
doesn't
one of them is mediocre by every
conceivable statistical measure while
the other is the greatest of all time
by every conceivable statistical measure
just so just a slight difference a
slight difference between
greatest of all time and not very good
but a world view that doesn't recognize
merit or taken into account and
fundamentally denies that marriage
merit should have any any any anything
to do with success
is bound to have some really really bad
sports takes
as this proves and as in fact espn
proves every single day
now with that said it is true that
kaepernick's politics
his protest played a factor in his not
having a job in the nfl for the past
five years
i mean absolutely but i think sometimes
conservatives make a mistake in denying
this
where they try to say oh it had nothing
to do with it no it did have something
to do with it it is true
that kaepernick was essentially
blackballed by the league
um it's also true that there are are
people in the league now
who are probably worse than him there
are quarterbacks in the league right now
that are probably
second second and third string
quarterbacks but there are second third
string quarterbacks
in the league right now who are um
not much better than him possibly worse
but he still deserved it he deserves to
be blackballed by the league he deserves
um to not have a job in the league there
are two very good reasons for that the
first is that he doesn't
seem to really want a job in the nfl all
that much
or at least he doesn't want it enough to
cool it with the fake freedom fighter
routine
the second if we could put the first to
the side for a moment the second is that
his mouth and his antics consistently
write
checks that his skills cannot cash this
is actually a good lesson for all of us
because you can
in life and especially in your career be
as big of a jerk as your skills and
therefore your value will compensate for
now it's better not to be a jerk at all
but if you're going to be a jerk
you better calibrate your jerkiness so
that it doesn't exceed your talent
that's the equation that's the
calculation you always have to make
tom brady could basically be as awful as
he wants to be because
he's going to come in he's going to
bring your team to a super bowl
single-handedly
so he could kind of be however he wants
but even with that being the case
he's really not that much of a jerk at
all and though he's accused of being
political
he's not political at all either
it's revealing how being friends with
someone donald trump in this case is
construed as a political statement by
the left
but whatever brady's politics are he's
not taking the the field in a maga hat
or doing anything else on the field to
call attention to his political
viewpoint
viewpoints he goes onto the field and he
plays the game and that's it
so the calculation for brady is very
simple he's a team player
he doesn't bring any unwanted attention
to himself or um or to his team
uh he's insanely great oh and he takes
less money in his contract than he has
to
so that his teams can spend money
elsewhere to bring in other good players
that makes him about the most
uncontroversial and obvious hiring
decision
imaginable he has made it so that for
his team
he represents all upside in every area
again there's a good lesson for us in
our own careers even if we're not
professional athletes
the goal is to be all upside or at least
to have enough upside to overshadow
your downside you want to be net upside
right what about kaepernick well here we
have almost exactly the reverse
situation he's a second string caliber
player at best doesn't have a winning
pedigree
turns the ball over a lot he's not a
great passer on top of all that he
brings a circus of media attention and
political attention
which he both craves and cultivates on
purpose he's a divisive presence
and you know as an owner or a coach that
if you bring him in he's going to accuse
you of racism
should you put him on the bench or cut
him due to his poor performance
you also know that there are dozens of
guys in the league who could bring you
the same kind of production as a player
but with none of the same headache so
this is another no-brainer
whereas tom brady is net upside cap is
net downside
whatever meager upside he has as a
player is vastly outweighed by the drama
he brings with him
that's why he doesn't have a job doesn't
deserve a job
though you know if you're concerned
there's no need to worry about him
starving to death fortunately he's
getting paid
millions of dollars by nike and a bunch
of other corporations
to walk around scowling and calling
people racist hell of a job if you can
get it
and when it comes to that job scowling
and calling people racist his abilities
are
undeniable um he isn't quite the tom
brady of race hustling that title
probably still belongs to sharpton
but he's well on his way we'll give him
credit for that as a football player
though
his career is dead and richly deserves
to be
and anyone who doesn't understand that
is canceled
and anyone who tries to make any point
about football without ever having
actually watched a game
is also very much cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content